-Il agace, il dérange,
sans doute parce qu'il fait
de la politique
loin des codes habituels.
Avec lui, la politique est
forcément un sport de combat,
avec pour ring TikTok
plutôt que l'hémicycle.
Générique
...
Bonjour, Louis Boyard.
-Bonjour.
-Votre arrivée à l'Assemblée
fait baisser
la moyenne d'âge des députés,
mais vous donnez aussi
un coup de jeune
à la communication politique.
On va le voir.
*-Madame la ministre,
face d'étudiants
devant les distributions
alimentaires,
votre action est aussi pauvre
qu'un sandwich du Crous.
*-Travailler, en études,
n'est pas négatif.
*-Ca apprend
la valeur travail.
L'Etat fait beaucoup.
*-Les bourses ont augmenté de 4 %
avec l'inflation.
*-Comment peut-on dire :
"Félicitez-nous,
4 % d'augmentation"
alors que seuls 38 %
des étudiants touchent la bourse ?
Une majorité ne la touche pas.
L'inflation est à 6 %.
Les étudiants ont perdu
de l'argent.
-Alors, ce qu'on vient de voir,
ce sont deux extraits
de vidéos postées
sur TikTok.
Elles ont fait plus de 4
et 5 millions et de vues,
je crois.
Je suis pas sûr
qu'un député ait fait autant de vues
avec des prises
de parole à l'Assemblée
ou en commission.
C'est une fierté,
pour vous, ça ?
-Là où on était étonnés,
c'était en commission.
Nous, en fait,
notre objectif,
c'est de s'approprier les codes
des réseaux sociaux,
ce sont aussi les nôtres.
J'utilise ces applications,
je regarde du contenu,
mon équipe aussi.
On utilise nos codes pour pouvoir
intéresser les jeunes
à la politique.
-C'est pour parler aux jeunes ?
-Oui, leur montrer
ce qui se passe à l'Assemblée,
de leur donner un argumentaire,
de leur donner des chiffres,
et leur montrer
notre position.
En fait,
la génération 2000 est entrée
à l'Assemblée
avec ses propres
codes culturels,
ses codes politiques aussi.
On les utilise et ça fonctionne.
-Ca vous vaut d'être appelé
le "député tiktokeur"
par vos adversaires.
Pour eux,
c'est pas un éloge.
Qu'en dites-vous ?
-Je m'en fiche.
Ce n'est pas à eux que je parle.
-Vous assumez ce côté
député tiktokeur ?
-En fait, j'assume d'être un député
qui essaye de parler aux jeunes.
Pour parler aux jeunes,
je ne vais pas le faire
de manière descendante,
en leur demandant
de s'institutionnaliser.
Au contraire,
je veux que l'institution
s'adapte aus jeunes,
qu'elle s'imprègne
de leur culture
pour les attirer
vers la politique.
On dit que la jeunesse se fiche
de la politique, c'est faux.
Elle n'a jamais été aussi politisée,
elle est ultra connectée,
elle est ultra informée.
Le problème, c'est
le décalage
entre les jeunes
et l'institution.
J'essaye de les reconnecter
en montrant des interventions
avec nos codes, j'y arrive.
-Sauf que parfois,
vos codes peuvent
choquer l'institution
de l'Assemblée.
Sur la réforme,
vous avez lancé
un concours sur Twitter
des meilleures photos de blocus
de lycée ou de campus.
A la clé : une visite
de l'Assemblée à vos côtés.
Ca vous a valu
une réplique sèche de la présidente
de l'Assemblée : "La politique
"n'est pas un challenge TikTok."
Vos adversaires vous ont reproché
d'abaisser la politique.
-Elle abaisse la politique
tous les jours, Yaëlle Braun-Pivet.
J'ai beaucoup de critiques
sur sa manière
d'user de sa fonction.
En vérité,
je lui demande pas son avis.
-Vous avez le sentiment
que ça tire
vers le haut, ça ?
-Je crois sincèrement que oui.
Au fond, que reprochent-ils
dans cette vidéo ?
C'est pas le fait
que j'utilise TikTok,
c'est pas le challenge.
Ils s'en fichent.
C'est le fait
que je reconnais aux jeunes
la légitimité de bloquer
leur établissement.
C'est mon opinion politique.
Je leur reconnais
cette légitimité
de faire des blocages.
Ca les a scandalisés.
Justement, on ramène des sujets
vis-à-vis de la jeunesse :
la légitimité de bloquer,
le réchauffement climatique,
la précarité...
Ce sont des choses
qu'ils ne veulent pas entendre.
Ils sont mauvais sur ces sujets.
Parce qu'on leur montre
la misère
que vivent les jeunes,
ils s'indignent
et ils préfèrent
regarder le doigt
plutôt que la Lune.
-Vous vous animez
et vous prenez un ton différent.
Ca m'intéresse.
Il y a votre façon de faire
de la politique
qui est différente.
Elle détone à l'Assemblée.
A peine élu député,
vous vous êtes fait remarquer
lors de la première séance.
Vous étiez là
en tant qu'assesseur
et vous avez refusé
de serrer la main des députés
du Rassemblement National.
C'était préparé
à l'avance ?
-Pas du tout.
Je me suis retrouvé
à cette place,
je n'avais pas envie
de leur serrer
la main.
-C'est pas un coup de com' ?
-C'était pas un coup médiatique.
Je pensais pas
que ça monterait comme ça,
mais ça a permis
de mettre en avant
un sujet politique :
l'institutionnalisation du RN
et ce qui était anormal
il y a 20 ans
est devenu normal.
Je voulais pas
leur serrer la main.
Je ne serre pas
la main des RN.
Parce que je pense
que ces gens ont
des idées politiques
nauséabondes et incompatibles
avec la République.
Je voulais pas le faire
parce que je suis comme ça.
Derrière, ça a fait du bruit
et on a utilisé ce bruit
pour porter un sujet politique
qui est
l'institutionnalisation du RN
dans l'Assemblée nationale.
-Vous donnez l'impression
de vivre votre engagement
comme un corps-à-corps
avec l'ennemi.
-Mais c'en est un.
-On va prendre des exemples.
Vous avez été blessé au pied
par un tir de Flash-Ball
pendant une manif
des gilets jaunes.
Vous avez rendu fou Cyril Hanouna
sur son plateau.
Il vous a traité de "tocard",
"merde" et bouffon".
Et des militants
d'extrême droite qui sont venus
vous menacer à la fac de Bordeaux
où vous vous êtes rendu
avec votre collègue
Carlos Martens Bilongo.
On a l'impression
que la politique devient
un combat de boxe, avec vous,
qu'il faut forcément une dose
d'agressivité,
voire de violence.
-Moi...
Vous pouvez regarder
dans tous les sujets,
je ne suis pas violent.
Des gens sont violents avec moi.
-Vous déclenchez l'agressivité ?
Vous ne vous sentez pas
agressif ?
-Non, je crois pas.
D'un autre côté,
je suis lucide en disant
qu'en politique,
il y a de la violence.
La politique,
c'est pas que des discours
sous les dorures.
Il y a des conséquences
dans la vie des gens
qui est violente, pour beaucoup.
La misère, la politique de Macron
et les mots du RN
sont violents.
-Votre mot d'ordre,
c'est de tenir tête.
Ca se traduit aussi à travers
votre politique ?
-Oui, bien sûr.
Oui, il faut leur tenir tête,
car on ne reconnaît pas
la légitimité à la jeunesse
de tenir tête
à la classe politique,
comme à beaucoup d'autres.
Oui,
c'est un combat politique.
Il faut l'assumer comme tel,
et c'est sain.
-La contrepartie de tout cela,
c'est que votre adresse
a été dévoilée
sur les réseaux sociaux,
sur Internet.
Vous avez été suivi
jusque chez vous,
vous avez reçu
à menaces à mort
chez vous.
Ca vous a valu
d'être placé
sous protection.
-Sous surveillance.
C'est le prix
de votre engagement ?
Vous le vivez comment ?
-C'est qu'on touche le bon bout.
Si jamais il y a des gens
qui sont
réduits à ça pour nous intimider,
c'est qu'on leur fait peur.
Du coup, j'ai envie de dire
"tant mieux".
-On va remonter un peu
dans le temps
pour voir que votre façon
de combattre, elle était là
dès vos tout débuts.
En fin 2017,
vous étiez lycéen,
on a détecté de l'amiante
dans votre établissement.
C'est à Villeneuve-le-Roi
et vous prenez la tête
de la mobilisation des élèves.
*-On est fatigués
de tout ça.
Et puis, il faut penser
à notre bac.
On a des élèves
en décrochage scolaire.
Ils ont arrêté les cours.
D'autres vont échouer
sur leur bac.
On est des victimes.
-C'est une de vos premières
interventions.
Je vous voyais rire.
-Ca me fait...
C'est drôle.
-De vous revoir à l'époque ?
-Ouais.
-Vous avez l'air vraiment
très à l'aise pour parler.
Comme si vous aviez fait ça
toute votre vie.
-A ce moment,
j'essayais d'expliquer
que laisser des élèves respirer
de l'amiante, c'est dangereux.
Je m'acharnais
à répéter des évidences
pour qu'elles soient entendues.
-Comment vous en êtes venu
à prendre la parole
au nom de vos camarades ?
-C'est parce qu'il y a eu
l'histoire avec l'amiante.
Avec les collègues
du lycée,
on s'est dit
qu'on allait monter
un syndicat pour se battre.
Ben, naturellement,
j'ai commencé
à prendre la parole.
-Des prédispositions ?
-Apparemment,
ça a fonctionné.
-Par la suite, vous êtes devenu
président de l'UNL,
l'Union Nationale Lycéenne.
Vous vous battez contre Parcoursup,
la réforme du bac et la politique
du président.
Comment vous vous êtes
politisé aussi jeune ?
-Bah, quand j'ai terminé
la lutte dans mon lycée...
On a bloqué
pendant trois mois
avec les professeurs
et leur droit de retrait.
Le lycée a été reconstruit.
L'un membre de mon syndicat
m'a parlé de Parcoursup.
Vu mon lycée pourri, j'ai plus
ou moins de chances qu'un autre ?
J'ai compris que j'étais de ceux
qui se feraient avoir.
Je me suis battu contre.
Après, il y a eu la réforme
du lycée, du bac,
et à chaque fois
que je m'engageais
dans une cause,
je découvrais
qu'il y en avait 1000 autres.
-Vous avez été
dans une grande précarité
pendant la durée de vos études.
Vous avez fait la manche parfois...
-Ca veut rien dire.
-...l'aide alimentaire
pour les étudiants,
vous en parlez souvent,
de ce sujet,
dans l'hémicycle.
Vous avez même dealé de la drogue
pour vous aider
à payer vos études.
Vous ne voulez plus en parler.
Pourquoi ?
-Plus en général, en fait,
c'est assez difficile
de pouvoir parler
de précarité étudiante
en parlant
de la sienne.
A chaque fois,
j'ai l'impression
qu'on rend la chose pathétique.
-En même temps,
ça vous donne
de la légitimité
pour en parler.
-Justement, la légitimité...
Il n'y a rien de pathétique
à la précarité étudiante.
Tout étudiant est précaire.
La manche,
c'est pas demander 2 euros
pour un sandwich.
La question de la drogue,
je n'ai pas envie d'en parler
parce qu'encore une fois,
on va plus parler de ça
et caricaturer,
que de parler
d'étudiants précaires.
C'est ça.
Quand j'essaye de parler de moi,
ou avec un effet médiatique
sur moi,
mon seul objectif,
c'est de parler de politique,
de parler de tout le monde.
Je fais justement attention
les sujets dont je parle,
car je veux pas être
le centre du sujet.
Le sujet,
c'est l'intérêt général.
-Aujourd'hui, vous gagnez
5841 euros net par mois,
comme député.
Vous dites :
"Je ne suis pas à l'aise.
"En quoi cette somme est justifiée ?
C'est indécent."
Il faudrait faire quoi,
selon vous,
pour mériter cette somme
en tant que député ?
-C'est pas une question de mérite
ou de rapport à soi,
mais de rapport aux autres.
Je fréquente des personnes
qui vivent avec 400 euros par mois.
Il y a autre chose
qui me marque,
c'est notre bureau de poste
à l'Assemblée
avec des fonctionnaires en nombre,
dévoués, compétents,
ouvert souvent,
et la poste de ma ville,
qui n'est quasiment pas ouvert.
Il y a un décalage
entre le service public,
le revenu qui est proposé
aux Français,
et notre service public
et notre revenu.
Ce décalage me met
mal à l'aise.
-Quel regard portez-vous
sur votre mandat de député ?
Est-ce que c'est à la hauteur
de ce que vous espériez ?
Vous êtes déçu,
frustré ?
-Avec la nouvelle composition
de l'Assemblée,
je pensais faire avancer
des sujets consensuels.
Sans majorité,
on pourrait
faire passer des lois.
Finalement, non.
Tout le monde est plus sectaire.
C'est difficile
de vraiment faire
avancer l'intérêt général
par nos propositions.
Mais on a des débats de fond,
l'Assemblée est regardée,
et ça ouvre
la bataille culturelle.
Je me sens à l'aise
à l'Assemblée
parce que je sais
que beaucoup ne m'aiment pas
et d'un autre côté, je cherche pas
à être aimé par eux,
mais à mener une bataille
regardée par les Français.
-On passe à notre quiz,
à présent.
Le principe :
je vais commencer une phrase
et c'est donc vous
qui allez la compléter.
Porter une veste
dans l'hémicycle,
c'est...
-C'est pas obligé de le mettre
dans le règlement.
-Mais vous le faites,
vous en portez une.
-Je n'ai pas le choix. Ils ont fait
un règlement de l'Assemblée.
-En dehors aussi.
-A tout moment,
vous devez pouvoir aller voter
à l'hémicycle.
Je suis toujours prêt
à aller voter.
-Une bonne prise de parole
doit forcément...
-Etre comprise.
Je dis ça parce que,
quand on parle à l'Assemblée,
ce n'est pas
que pour les députés,
on parle à ceux
qui nous regardent.
On parle plus à eux,
d'ailleurs.
Il faut être intelligible
pour le public
auquel on parle
et c'est ce qu'on fait
sur les réseaux.
-Pour conclure,
vous avez été élu à 22 ans,
vous vous voyez en politique
jusqu'à 70 ans
comme Jean-Luc Mélenchon ?
-C'est une question que je me pose.
-Avocat,
vous en rêviez.
-Je rêve toujours
d'être avocat pénaliste.
Je pense faire ça
dans ma vie.
Voilà, j'aimerais.
-Merci d'être venu dans l'émission.
-Merci.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA